Switzerland votes no to a guaranteed
monthly income proposals which would
force the Swiss government to pay each
of its citizens the equivalent of nearly
$1,800 about two thousand twenty two
hundred dollars a month whether or not
they are working have been rejected the
introduction of a quote unconditional
national income unquote had been
proposed as a means of tackling poverty
and inequality but it was derided as a
quote marxist dream by critics which it
is the final result resort results
showed about 77% of Swiss voters opposed
the plan in a national referendum which
is like a slam dunk
the government at urge citizens to vote
no after 100,000 signatures supporting
the move had forced a referendum
advocates argued that because robots
machines and computers are increasingly
replacing humans in the workplace and
don't need to be paid a salary workers
could be freed from the drudgery of
employment if the state stepped in to
support them here's the problem marxist
socialists and communists forget that
the government doesn't have any money
anywhere except money it took from
someone who is producing money
government creates no money the only way
the government has money is if it took
it from one of us and so the only way
that it would have money to give these
people's if it took more from other
people
thus Marxism communism one of the best
vacations ever had my life was about 18
months ago Sharon and I spent 10 days in
Switzerland an absolutely fabulous
country absolutely fabulous very
industrious people just brilliant and
kind there's you know the French side
the German side and it is the influence
of the culture and so forth it's just an
amazing country we absolutely enjoyed it
and I will go back it is probably
the most enjoyable European countries
I've ever visited actually it is just um
again it's a little expensive I will say
that I mean like eating dinner in Geneva
chi-ching right it's like eating dinner
in London or in New York City I mean
it's it's pretty pricey but it's it was
fabulous we had an absolutely stellar
time just the two of us and you know it
really enjoyed the country enjoyed the
people enjoyed everything and I'm really
glad to see them vote this down but you
know it's always interesting the
Socialists always point out and the ones
running for office in the US and all
that I always point out these little
tiny European countries which you know
you think of Switzerland it's quote a
legitimate country it is a legitimate
country and they just voted down Marxism
and communism congratulations way to go
guys and here's the thing 8.1 million
people how many people live in Dallas
eight million people in the Dallas
Metroplex Switzerland is the size of
Dallas does that give you a little
perspective I'm talking about
geographically or culturally or age or
heritage I'm talking about the number of
human beings and by the way the economic
production is very similar the gross
domestic product of Switzerland is
pretty close to the rose domestic
product of Dallas and so this is like
Dallas making a decision which Dallas
wouldn't even this wouldn't even made
the referendum because Texas is still
part of America right but parts of
America are confused and think they're
not part of America anymore but I mean
people that live in Dallas
they're capitalists I'll just tell you
Texans yay Texas we love Texas
Tennesseans and Texans have always
gotten along and all for a lot of
reasons but I mean you know it's just
just ridiculous and for those of you
what about Norway Norway
I mean Atlanta is bigger than Norway
shut up I mean you guys discuss these
things like they're like there's some
kind of big kind of proof of this
socialism crap you know we're touring
Sweden and enjoyed it again very nice
people
economy's nowhere near as robust as
Switzerland but you know we're going
through their little tour guides going
you know we have free college education
we have free this and free that and free
this and finally I had a American belly
full of her free and I'm like so what is
your personal income tax rate sixty five
percent
I missed where you got free out of that
chick there's no free there well I don't
pay that much in taxes yeah but there's
no free there is no free health care
there is no free college education there
is no free retirement plan quit saying
crap is free that comes from the
government it makes you look stupid
because it's not free and if the idiots
that put this thing on the Swiss ballot
had gotten their way an unconditional
national income would have been free not
because somebody has to pay for this
crap somebody needs to remind you people
the government does not pay for anything
it takes money from other people to pay
for things there is no free I saw a
doofus from the Democrats there they go
this is going to destroy the lockbox on
the Social Security system like dude
there's been no money in the lockbox of
the Social Security system in decades it
was destroyed long ago Social Security
system is completely cash flowed out of
Congress any money that was in there was
stolen long ago and spent you know how
Social Security gets paid they collect
more than they put out it's not there's
no lockbox there is no money set aside
in the Social Security system it's not
even set aside at all they just
completely take it and spend it however
they want they just happen to spent it
and take in enough to be able to pay the
Social Security bill Social Security is
not free subsidized housing is not free
health care is not free free is it has
no cost come in we have failed our
children in basic economic education
where they walk around going I want free
on free college education they might be
free too
you doofus but the rest of us are going
to be paying for it and some of us are
not confused about that we know where
the money came from out of our back
pocket so the next time someone wants to
make the argument that a European
country is somehow socialist European
country is somehow stellar remind them
that it's probably not the size of
Dallas in this case we are highlighting
a European country that is stellar and
did do a great job called Switzerland
where to go Swiss the right-wing Swiss
part People's Party argued that the
country's open border agreement with the
EU would lead to people pouring into the
country and take advantage of the scheme
do you think yeah under the European
Union in other words you can come and go
at will a lot of people don't live in
Switzerland working Switzerland drive in
every day today we saw the traffic jams
when we were there actually sat in one
at one point and those are people that
don't work in the country that are
working that or they don't live in the
country that are working in the country
they choose to live in France and drive
across the line and which is part of the
European Union deal but guess what if
you had a free income an unconditional
national income does that not make you
want to just blow your man Charlie it's
unbelievable yeah this is the kind of
crap that's coming around here because
we've taught people or didn't teach
people how basic economics works that
there is nothing from the government
that is free those roads you drive on
they weren't free somebody paid for them
with property taxes or income taxes they
weren't free there is no free stop
telling people stuff is free from the
government it makes you look stupid
because you are it's not free it can't
be free if it came from the government
it came from someone else they took
money from someone else and gave it to
your program and it might be free to you
but it's not free
II don't have a free anything we the
people pay for crap through the
government and oh by the way it takes
about two dollars to get 70 cents worth
through the government black hole
actually back out into the marketplace
it's a fairly inefficient extremely
inefficient method of wealth transfer
for you inequality doobs that are out
there so quit trying to talk that
through it doesn't even work
mathematically it's not free this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind